i
la sociedad hondureña se mantiene
dividida a raíz de la decisión del
congreso nacional de blindar la ley
contra el aborto esta decisión ha sido
tomada de buena manera por
organizaciones ligadas a la comunidad
religiosa mientras tanto las
organizaciones feministas y defensoras
de los derechos humanos ha lanzado su
voz de protesta ellas se pedían la
modificación de esta ley y la
despenalización del aborto en tres casos
excepcionales malformación del feto
embarazo producto de violaciones y
cuando la vida de la madre está en
peligro sin embargo estas observaciones
no fueron tomadas en cuenta por el
parlamento hondureño por otro lado la
organización de las naciones unidas la
onu ha pedido al parlamento una
reconsideración a esta decisión tomada
consideran que honduras es uno de los
países que tiene las más elevadas tasas
de natalidad y de embarazos en
adolescentes 1 de cada 3 alumbramientos
una adolescente menor de 19 años
[Música]
la aprobación del aborto de la vecina
argentina que fue seguida de cerca por
muchos grupos feministas en chile- ha
reactivado un proyecto de ley que venía
durmiendo desde hace más de dos años y
medio en el congreso chileno la comisión
de mujer y equidad de género formado por
diputadas y de mayoría opositora está
escuchando a las partes en un debate que
se prevé arduo y extenso en el tiempo y
para el que no hay un plazo determinado
en caso de que decidiera aprobar la idea
de despenalizar el aborto en el país
esta idea de legislar todavía debería de
ser aprobada tanto por la cámara de
diputados- como por el senado esta
comisión evalúa que entre 30.000 y
150.000 mujeres abortan clandestinamente
en chile- todos los años un país en el
que el aborto terapeútico en tres
causales por violación riesgo de vida
del feto o riesgo de vida de la madre
todavía se aprueba in extremis en el
2017 y en la práctica enfrenta muchas
trabas tanto de objeción de conciencia
de los facultativos como de maltrato
velado entre otras para aquellas mujeres
que quieren ejercer legítimamente su
derecho
[Música]
en méxico a diferencia de otros países
no se impulsará desde el ejecutivo
federal la despenalización del aborto el
presidente lópez obrador no sólo ha
dejado en claro que no enviará al
congreso una iniciativa al respecto sino
que incluso ha causado polémica al
sugerir que se lleve a cabo una consulta
popular sobre el tema la secretaria de
gobernacion oiga sánchez cordero que se
ha expresado a favor de que sea una
decisión de las mujeres precisó que los
derechos no se pueden someter a consulta
y que en todo caso se discutiría el tipo
penal y es que en el país entre enero y
diciembre de 2020 se tuvo un registro de
633 abortos catalogados como delitos del
fuero común únicamente la ciudad de
mexico y oaxaca tienen legalizada la
interrupción del embarazo antes de las
12 semanas de gestación desde la
perspectiva de salud pública han
disminuido las muertes por abortos
clandestinos sin embargo el tema sigue
siendo una de las principales causas de
grupos feministas sobre todo desde el
punto de vista del derecho a decidir
[Música]